I was saying he was innocent but I
didn't believe him he shot me right in
the nagy the hallway the loading dock in
here and even the back courtyard I have
no idea what's going on we are playing
trouble in terrorist town or TTT for
traitors five innocents and one
detective who is a publicly known
innocent to the traitors job is
eliminate all the other players and the
innocence figure out who the traitors
are before the traders can murder them
the plot twists innocence don't know who
the traitors are
you're gonna my deputy that means you
stay in front of me we go on the stage
oh it's okay I've got it
I'm good at the sex good on the stage
don't want to stand behind me
trying to get Sam dude somewhere sweet
really he's not fired over there rich it
is he dead Geron check it out
[Applause]
detective
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah Brenda dude just kind of confuse
that's out of place guys look at you
look at the camera you want you can do
whatever you want okay hey guys so this
is Danny and Richie from raka raka well
sure why he's here
and raka raka is probably the number one
stunt team on YouTube in my opinion they
do awesome action to tell some great
stories they have more character in
their videos than like 99% of the people
that I see out there so wait who plays
Ronald McDonald is eight years and nice
between it's Michael moves with tell me
a little bit about like your team so you
have a twin brother and then you have
some other guys working with you too
like aw does what my VFX guy jacked up
coordinator as well Josh yeah so
professional baguette in suit these
things always seem to go wrong
yeah so yeah that's pretty much the team
very jealous of your office we don't the
lawyers yeah where comes in handy
watching your channel you like are
constantly getting hit by cars
no jumping off your balcony multiple
times how do you do that not get killed
well yeah it's like let's say the maiden
stunt stop tested is more Michael so I
like I'll write it and shoot it and
direct it and then Michael act in it and
do sound effects and music Mike was like
he's a stopper for my so he's that
verified stop man it was the hardest
thing you've had to do yeah so my
brother did like a live wrestling
matches wrong
she doesn't break his nose and he had
like a proper stock job like the next
day and I so he couldn't go so I had to
go pretend to be Mike what I'm doing it
was like a Simo such a labor scene sit
like a wall running I jump into this
ditch it was like it wasn't that high
it's not like this hide here and like
they had these like really solid wall
boots on it was like a really hard
ground and I was like what we've got my
Raelynn job buzzing oh that drools and
I'm like are you gonna do it again
okay well not chopped again every time I
did it it was early and I was like to
the point where I got like yeah let's go
again jumped and he says that landed I
felt this pain just go right up my legs
off and the cameras on me not like this
in the background all right literally I
tried to walk I couldn't then like we
pulled off my mud boots now like both my
legs are the small a car it's hard to do
you use that the right of it and hope
you don't die okay you guys think we're
really pro or not
oh look yeah but like I said how do you
practice for that you [ __ ] your legs or
run them over
oh yeah yeah I've been actually proven
the cocky w few minutes I do
gerrae once and it was scary I feel like
I'm the one most responsible ones dead
if someone actually did come along and
was like someone died it would be my
father wouldn't ya would be today we
fight for the honor of lady Squarespace
that's right
and she is the sponsor of this video and
so many other videos in the past today
we fight for her honor and any Knight
who was able to strike a true strike on
his opponent gets to tell you one great
thing about Squarespace I don't think
Sir Nicholas of the Blackwater has
anything on Sir Jacob of the forest but
we'll find out I mean I think I'm gonna
be telling you guys a lot of cool stuff
sire my heart beats with the ease of an
easily customizable website template my
heart yearns for her 24/7 award-winning
customer service
in your pain you must realize that
Squarespace has an all-in-one platform
with nothing to patch install or upgrade
ever
screw except a unique domain experience
so it's fully transparent and if you're
looking for a URL you can get it at
Squarespace without having to go to a
third party I will tell them about lady
squares or little no other any offer
code I will tell them your swings have
the potency of a baby tadpole a baby
tadpole I think you mean a giant frog
you sir will not have the honor go to
squirts prince.com slash [ __ ] no crew
and get 10%
first purchase squarespace.com / Goku
especially Sam
especially made
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you die I have to dedicate this game to
Gabe who died in silence with no
witnesses if you don't want to talk
about this on the interview you don't
have to but oh no what you're gonna say
we're talking about the the backflip off
the um yeah the cliff so the the stun
actress miscalculated and she and she
didn't push out and it was like a human
error or whatever it was hitting the
rocks on the way down but she was still
I care while she's in the footage and
like it was terrifying it was like
literally one of the scariest moments
ever and our live stream I'm stuck gone
wrong video is completely based on that
experience like that anxiety of everyone
going quiet and like not knowing if
something's a chaotic out see that guy's
fingers cigarette at you so from then on
it was like extra portion on top of the
caution and when you're already have to
stop coordinated said it is already like
really that controlled environment like
there was divers in the water like the
water was broke him of like all these
tanks and stuff and it was like she was
like a gold medalist like an Olympic
diver or something she was like a proper
proper diver that was especially stunt
was those sort of stunts and they're
still it can still go wrong like starts
go wrong people die you know who died
what was recently Deadpool to you the
style actress died so I guess the moral
of the story for that Neruda stunt is
that wasn't CG that wasn't a dummy we're
just watching somebody fall down because
try to shut that much out of life if we
stop person does that and you don't use
the footage it seems like like Alex some
people don't like it's disrespectful or
like yeah yeah you got to use the
footage yeah yeah runs a villain oh man
I'm a traitor do not trust me
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
detective ah
there's so many dad it's so hard to
distinguish what's happening I'm gonna
take it who's less alright I want both
you guys to go up there go up top
right in front of my eyes I was right
here there was just chaos just erupted I
saw shoot somebody he I he was saying he
was innocent but I didn't pull away from
but that I started you she shot me right
in the new key hey dude
thanks for coming out yeah yeah you guys
are very good at tea tea tea actually
hey you should go check out their
channel it's amazing it's one of the few
channels I actually watch all the time
on YouTube oh yeah here we go right
there I'll check out corridor digital
yeah I like them so much I even own this
shirt
the one he's wearing right now yeah I
saw it go flying on you crap